and the golden globe goes to
chadwick boseman accepting on behalf of
chadwick boseman
is his wife simone ledford boseman
the late chadwick boseman won the 2021
golden globe for best performance by an
actor for his work in ma rainey's black
bottom
his wife simone accepted the award on
his behalf
he would thank god he would thank his
parents
he would thank his ancestors for their
guidance and their sacrifices
naturally she got emotional during her
speech
detailing what she thought chadwick
would say if he were there
he would say something beautiful
something inspiring something that would
amplify that little voice inside of all
of us that tells you you can
that tells you to keep going simone also
listed off several members of chadwick's
team
and ma rainey's black bottom cast
members he would thank ms viola davis
mr glen turman mr michael potts
mr coleman domingo miss taylor page
mr duson brown ahead of the show et
spoke with his close friend and former
co-star angela bassett
who couldn't wait to see how the globes
honored chadwick's legacy
my heart my son chadwick is up for an
award so
look forward to you know to just see his
face
on the screen pop up on the screen there
who knows what will happen
it's nice to to remember and recall his
brilliance and his spirit
so looking forward to that and really
just to celebrate
all of my colleagues and to do so safely
it does break our heart to have to honor
him posthumously and to speak
about him in the past tense but you know
you know his work
you work with him like you said he is
your film son to see him honored and
lifted up in this way how does that make
you feel
it's a sweet spirit it's a sweet feeling
in my heart
we miss him terribly but he was kind of
individual in the kind of work
he did is worthy of remembrance so i'm
glad
that we are doing the uh the most
beautiful and righteous thing
in doing so